Mire, ¿qué sabes tú con 27 años? ¿Qué sabes tú?
Nosotros hemos vivido la Primera Guerra Mundial,
la verdad, que se me dejaron todo el día, y los nuestros fueron
comer, no comer, en su cama.
Mire, aquí no va cama, aquí no va piso.
Podría ser palabroso.
Puede ser cromano, así.
Yo me quisiera
a Rusia, dejar todo.
Entonces mi mamá,
que era mujer mayor,
el suegro mío empezó, mire.
La señora mía, era una hija.
¿Cómo yo voy a dejar al papá?
Con los cuñados,
hermanos, ese hermano ya no estaba allá.
Usted sabe una cosa, ¿no?
El Dios también se puede conocer.
En la historia,
ay, no quiero decir qué, ya está.
No quiero tanto entrar en detalles en la historia de...
me quedó.
Pero en mi principio,
la señora
sigue allá.
Yo llamo a mi hermano, que tiene 25%,
y llamo al señor,
vamos a sentarse a la mesa.
¿Qué va a decir?
Yo veo situación malísima, muy mala.
Aquí va guadito como escribe el periódico,
y ya he oído de mucha gente que son pesimistas.
Hablando con energía.
¿Qué quiere decir?
Yo quiero, inmediatamente,
ponerse la guerra en nombre de Kulovich,
que él es dueño,
y nosotros estamos manejando ese negocio.
¿Qué te pasó?
¿Estás loco?
Mire, señores, así quiero yo.
O yo me retiro,
o se hace como yo quiera.
En fin, pensaron,
yo me salí de mi casa,
estaba nervioso,
comí algo y me puse a dormir.
Viene mi hermano.
¿Sabes qué te digo?
El señor me dice que tienes razón.
Inmediatamente se me pusieron en nombre de él.
Tuve que marchar a mi molino, completo,
tradera todo.
Yo tenía muchos capinteros que compraron tablas,
que hicieron muebles, una cosa.
Ustedes saben que en Polonia
eran Volksdeutsche,
alemanes que nacieron en Polonia.
Como está aquí, mire, en Venezuela,
mire, romanos,
checos,
judíos, todo lo que está aquí,
así era en Polonia.
Era Volksdeutsche,
eran bastantes Volks allá.
Eran dos hijos de un capintero
que ellos compraron
y cuando salieron con tablas,
el ruso que controlaba con la factura,
cuántas tablas hay,
sale correcto con la factura.
Teníamos gente trabajando mucho en eso.
Entonces, que cuida ya, mire,
ellos hicieron tablas para adentro
y para afuera se quedaron no viendo
y él descubrió.
Entonces me llevaron a mí,
yo estaba en mi oficina exacto,
y dice el señor Reis, mi polaco,
que la gente se llevaron más tablas
que compraron la factura,
y dice, ya vinieron empresas,
ya quitaron, y descubrieron que era así.
A mí me gusta nunca ser un humano,
un humano es muy bien hacer, mire.
Entonces me dijo, mire, señor,
quítale que llevaron más
y que compraron, que se vaya.
Ya tenemos los alemanes
y estos dos polacos,
los alemanes y los polacos,
se quedaron agravados.
Era cada país feo,
la gente son como ladrones,
y vinieron a mi casa
y me dijeron,
tú dijiste que Hitler es perro.
Para esto, mire, la muerte,
no hay que hablar alemán, le dicen eso.
Imagínate ese momento de mi señora,
de mi mamá, de mi suegro,
de mi hermano, cómo era.
La cosa era horrible.
Ya, soy primero como principio de la guerra.
¿Ya había estallado la guerra?
¿Cómo? Sí, ya hablamos ya de la guerra,
39, septiembre.
Ya.
Entonces me llevan.
De mi señora,
para otra donde era
comandatura, se llama alemán comandatura,
vamos a decir, completamente alemanes.
Ya cuando vinieron para allá, mire,
cualquier cosa, ya fue cerrado.
En camino,
me están llevando,
con dos caballos,
¿qué usted va a tener de esto que me matan a mí?
¿Qué usted va a ganar?
Yo puedo usted dar bastante dinero que me dejan libre.
Pararon, caballo,
¿cuánto das tú?
Suma, no puede acordar.
Se me llegaron a acuerdo.
Mañana usted viene a las 12,
yo doy usted el dinero.
¿Cuánto me dejaron libre?
Milletamente.
Yo no dio ellos nada y me fui para la ciudad.
Dejo todo, marcha,
molino, serratera, todo,
y dije mi señora, agárrale a un polaco,
cuánto cuesta, venga con tu papá,
para la ciudad.
¿A qué ciudad?
Para Bogdano.
Yo exacto estuve como,
era,
polacos con rusos,
guerra, siguiendo,
y ya estaban alemanes,
y estuve siguiendo la guerra,
los polacos con rusos.
¿Pero en dónde estaba su esposa?
Bueno, en ciudad,
dijeron que van a acabar toda ciudad.
Entonces me llegaron para,
Petiste,
para allá, para Molino.
Entonces me dejaron todo,
y me fueron para la ciudad.
Ciudad ya no, a mí no podía encontrar,
ya estaba bien, ya escondido.
Bueno, allá mire,
ya también alemanes,
polacos,
de la casa,
tablas,
molino,
todos sacaron a morir,
todos que saben,
ya,
una vida libre,
ya los soviéticos no tenían derecho a nada.
¿Usted tenía el cerradero y todo en Petiste?
Sí.
¿Y su casa en Boldagua?
Allá vivía,
mi selva vivía allá,
todo vivía,
uno que viajaba, mire,
tenía,
tenía mis gentes trabajando,
siempre fui,
bajo control todo, ¿no?
Era un gran riqueza.
Allá pasó,
la guerra.
Tenemos,
regresar,
por atrás explicar un asunto.
De éste tres,
treinta y seis socios,
era un socio,
se llamaba Blank,
y la señora,
se llamaba Perla,
y cinco hijas,
muy preciosas.
Este señor Perla,
era muy religioso,
y siempre conmigo hablaba,
siempre cuando yo tenía tiempo,
dije mi señor Meyer,
¿cómo tú pudiste llegar,
un muchacho pobre,
que es de toda mi historia,
mi suegro lo explicó,
ella muy religiosa,
¿cómo tú llegaste?
Dije, querida mi señora,
con mucho sudor,
con mucho trabajo,
y una cosa más importante,
el brazo de Dios,
el brazo derecho de Dios.
Me ignoró,
me acuerdo que me dio un beso aquí.
Pasó la cosa.
Entonces,
uno tiene que vivir,
yo tenía dinero,
tenía dinero,
tenía donde vivir,
y ya empezaron a trabajar,
y nuestras herederas,
adonde me hicieron,
mi suegra hablaba,
en nombre de Korolevich.